Oh
um well there's a plus and a minus side
to that I would say I mean yes of course
it's a huge concern that you know the
numbers are really frightening of what
percentage of people have saved enough
to retire and now with the recession you
know it's only added to that and people
have seen what they thought was enough
to retire on shrink so that's all very
worrisome and and you know the whole
economic situation is is a worry but
having said that you know I think that
we're going to come to think about work
differently as people get older and
older and what I said earlier about
engagement for a lot of people they do
find that in their work so personally I
think you know the ideal situation is if
an older person can cut back in in their
work requirements you know they're not
locked into that nine to five you know
hectic lifestyle anymore but but that
they do have the ability to pursue
something that they find meaningful and
that might be in the world of work or it
might be outside of a paid job but but
so as I said it's a plus and minus
answer I think some people are going to
have to keep working longer but the
silver lining there is if if you have to
keep longer working longer at something
that is meaningful to you that at that I
think is actually good for your health
Yoga is really I think a great great
pursuit first of all it's really
beneficial physically and you know you
probably know there's many different
schools of yoga so you can probably go
down the block here to a gym wear
they're doing power yoga you know it's
extremely physically taxing and or a lot
of people have a kind of an idea about
yoga you know they see pictures of
Yogi's and these terribly complicated
pretzel like poses and they just know
that that's not for them you know they
could never do that so you know and and
that's a certain approach to yoga which
i think is especially prevalent in our
society because you know we tend to be
very competitive athletically and you
know we want to do those complicated
poses but you know the kind of the true
roots of yoga our yoga as a meditative
practice it as I said it falls under the
umbrella of mind-body medicine because
yoga is really a way of bringing the
mind into focus that's how how it
originated the ancient Yogi's developed
yoga both as a preparation for sitting
meditation you know so your body would
be able to sit for long periods of time
but they also conceived of it as a form
of meditation so meditation is really
just focusing your mind so in yoga you
focus your mind on your body and you
really bring your full attention to body
movements but so the physical aspects of
yoga are extremely beneficial and we've
seen that we've offered yoga at the
martha stewart center now for about
about six years and you would just be
amazed at some of our patients who
started with yoga you know quite a few
years ago with us and i mean we
literally have people in their 70s 80s
and 90s who you know could barely get
down onto the ground or they couldn't
get down onto the ground when they
started and they've just enormously
improved in their flexibility their
strength their mobility and they love it
it's a great it's a great form of social
engagement as well so it's extremely
good physically and and there's a lot of
new and interesting research in a whole
lot of different ways that Yoga is
beneficial and you start to you start to
see
Yoga studies creeping in even to the
conventional medical literature not very
often but if I pick up my annals of
internal medicine you know which is the
leading journal in internal medicine I
remember I think was last year there was
a study showing that yoga was more
effective than standard physical therapy
for low back pain for instance so so you
know there's more research going on to
document the benefits of yoga I just did
a small study with a great yoga teacher
her name is Nancy elks who was
recommended to me by one of our lung
specialist at Mount Sinai he said you
know my patients with emphysema which is
a terrible disease you know he said one
of them said to me you know doctor dr.
DePaolo I love you but you know yoga has
done more for me than all of your
medicines haven't so he got interested
and started referring his patients to
this young woman Nancy elks who I had
the great opportunity to work with
recently we did a little yoga study on
having people with serious lung disease
these are people with really pretty
pretty major league emphysema learn yoga
techniques that helped their muscles of
breathing and then importantly I think
improved their strength and their
endurance and they loved it and
benefited